what's up  hey  come on you're all like running around  come on run around let's run around  about you  yeah  come on come on where are we going  where are we going  where are we going  yeah i'm still following you  i'm still following you what's going on  you want your messy  you want to yeah with your mouth  i got your mousy  yeah you want to get it  good girl  [Laughter]  chase in her mouth  goodness that was a good one  that was a good one again you want to  get  wow  let's do it again let's do it again  let's do it again ready  wow  good girl  good girl  yeah  all right here we go here we go here we  go you ready you ready  you seem like you're losing interest  [Laughter]  yeah you being silly me and silly  okay  do you like it right i'm done  i'm done